that night the greatest gladiator match
in the history of the world son of
krypton vs bat of Gotham
God vs Man golden pig in yucaipa
duke snider on top
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie looks like
new Batman V Superman footage just
dropped just hyping up the crazy action
so let's break it down Batman powering
up the bat signal to goad Superman into
a fight remember before this Superman
told Batman that the bat is supposed to
be dead dismantle your bad signal the
next time it fires on don't answer it
what better way to go the Boy Scout into
a fight than to do the exact thing that
he told you not to do and even though
the scenes we see in trailers are cut
non sequentially from the movie like
they just take bits and pieces of the
movie and Jan them together right after
Batman fires the bat signal on after a
flash of lightning boom Superman is
there it would an awesome way to think
about Superman a blue and red streak of
lightning this place that the Batmobile
is driving past that Lois Lane is
walking through this is the place
Superman killed Zod during Man of Steel
you can see that it's been turned into
something of a mausoleum now it's kind
of like a tomb much better shot of the
Batman nightmare sequence there's
actually a couple different scenes from
the sequence in here broken up I'm
wondering how long this dream sequence
is going to go and I'm just assuming
that it's a dream sequence because they
get information from a future version of
Barry Allen who's traveled back in time
then it probably gives them some crazy
nightmares I'm guessing that's why
they're calling this nightmare Batman
more from that bat is dead scene do you
bleed you will a lot of new Batmobile
action I would say this is probably the
most functional Batmobile next to the
tumbler it's a little more agile than
the tumbler but I love the way they made
the modern Batmobiles like these last
two big movie Batmobiles so functional
Zack Snyder even brought the Batmobile
to Comic Con last year the exhaust is so
loud that you could hear it all over
downtown San Diego wonder woman looking
like she's getting ready to board that
Turkish Airlines plane we actually
learned a little bit more about what's
going on with her character in the movie
her real world persona the Diana Prince
persona is actually an antiquities
dealer if she's about 5,000 years old
when the movie picks up if you were
functionally immortal you would probably
be selling antiques too if you watched
any of the Highlander movies that's what
the Connor MacLeod character does all
the mundane things that he's collected
during his life became rare artifacts by
modern day so he's all the super
valuable stuff Batman beating the [ __ ]
out of these criminals there's just more
scenes from this warehouse scene that
we've seen in earlier trailers couple
flashback scenes from Man of Steel
couple of people have thought
Lois Lane being underwater is going to
be tied to an Aquaman scene I really
think that Aquaman is going to show up
later in the movie and it's going to
have something to do with what the
Kryptonians did when they tried to
terraform the earth they somehow harm
the Earth's oceans and then some of the
fallout of Lex Luthor's experiments with
metahumans like doomsday that's going to
bring Aquaman into the limelight because
they'll be searching for other
metahumans really wondering with this
nuclear looking Blastoise either it's
part of the nightmare sequence or this
is something to do with Lex Luthor's
experiments Batman head-butting the crap
out of Superman this heat vision scene
of Superman looking like he's getting
ready to waste someone is actually from
a Lex Luthor scene so maybe this is when
Superman finds out about Lex Luthor's
experiments like you did what with Zod's
body you've been experimenting with
radioactive pieces of my homeworld so if
there was ever a movie to buy on blu-ray
I feel like this is gonna be it just so
iconic looking no matter how you feel
about the story it's going to look
beautiful usually the only blu-rays that
I buy nowadays are the movies that look
amazing or that I have some sort of deep
personal connection to like anything
Star Wars Marvel DC complete auto buys
but this really is one of those movies
that you should definitely see an imax
if you have the opportunity i know the
big imax theaters aren't everywhere but
it really melts your brain so much more
than the normal presentation if you
haven't been reading it you also have to
check out Dark Knight 3 it's not a
tie-in comic it's not related to Batman
V Superman it's just Frank Miller's
sequel to dark knight returns to and
it's so fun to read it while you're
watching all this Batman V Superman
stuff that is the comic to read while
you're getting hyped up for the movie
which is now within the 10-day window
some of you depending on where you live
might even get to see the movie this
week most of the rest of us are going to
be watching daredevil this weekend
Batman V Superman will be coming next
week so let me know in the comments what
kind of bonus videos do you guys want me
to do for it before it gets here I think
what's the movie drops and I do my
easter egg video and my spoilery review
what I'll probably do is more justice
league stuff like the flash movie
Aquaman the Batman trilogy The Wonder
one movie like all the spin-off movies
that are going to be happening so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
they'll probably a little bit more
Batman V Superman later this week but
there's still a whole bunch of Captain
America Civil War happening new
daredevil so now is the time for maximum
hype and just a heads up my Gotham video
night will post to my facebook page
there's a link for that at the bottom of
the description it's just facebook.com /
emergency awesome well he gives way for
me to post my next video you can click
here for my Black Panther Civil War
video and you can click here for all my
Batman V Superman videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight